wax your ball you wax your balls and
prepare to get the crap kicked out of
you because we have the worst wedding
anniversary ever
yes Black Mirror is back with the
surprisingly happy ending in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into
striking vipers ending as well as some
of the episodes Easter eggs so if you
want to jump right to the Easter eggs
I've left a timestamp in the description
at its core striking Vipers is the story
of Danny a middle aged family man who
must come to terms with his own
sexuality at the beginning of the
episode he's filled with passion
role-playing with his girlfriend at the
bar and having sex with her on the
counter of their bathroom their
relationship is strong and you can tell
these two are deeply into each other
it's not until 11 years later that
Danny's perfect life isn't all it's
cracked up to be even though he has the
American dream a house in the suburbs
doting wife and child
he still longs for something more
staring at multiple women like the one
at his birthday party and another from
across the street the passion that Danny
and Theo used to have is gone and part
of him still yearns for that their sex
life today is mechanical timed out on an
app and regulated to increase their
chances of having another baby
Theo calls Danny out on this saying you
don't touch me anymore not to mention
how many times Danny uses the I'm too
tired excuse to avoid having sex with
his wife this has an adverse effect on
Theo who questions if she's good enough
she checks her body out in the mirror as
if trying to see what's wrong with her
she herself looks at others making out
remembering when she used to be like
that but unlike Danny
Theo doesn't give in to these
temptations even when she's approached
at the bar by another man as she later
tells Danny partnerships are about
commitment and you need to make
sacrifices in order for it to work which
leads us to Danny and Carl Carl gets
Danny for his birthday an immersive new
video game called striking Vipers in
which each player is brought into the
game using state-of-the-art VR
technology at first Danny loves this his
knee which he damaged years ago isn't a
problem here the same can't be said with
his feelings for Carl striking Vipers is
also a metaphor for Danny and Carl's
desires which is contrasted with Tetris
whereas Tetris is cookie cutter and Carl
calls it boring
to fit pieces into a set box striking
Vipers is exciting sexy and raw this
acts as a juxtaposition between Danny's
real world and fantasy world over the
next few months the two men continue
their affair which only causes more
damage to Danny and Theo's relationship
Danny even forgets about his wedding
anniversary as Theo says about Danny
I mean you shrivel away you go inside
leave me on the outside Danny has now
quenched his desire for passion at the
expense of his relationship with Thea
and things continue to get worse as Carl
and Danny fall deeper in love with each
other
the same is true with Carl and his
relationship with Mariela the first
scene with the two of them sets up that
they probably aren't meant for each
other I mean come on
she doesn't even know who Dennis Rodman
is later on in the episode Karl can't
even get it up when he's with her he's
in love with Danny which begs the
question is it cheating when Danny tells
Karl he can no longer see him Karl tries
to convince him it's not saying it's no
different than watching porn but Danny
doesn't really buy it and I don't either
when Karl tries to get Danny back he
tells him how he experimented with other
people in the game even other people who
played the same avatar as him Lance for
Karl it wasn't the character he was
attracted to it was the man behind it
Danny and the same can also be said for
Danny he sends a message to Karl with
the X kiss symbol and he's the one to
suggest they kiss at the end to see if
what they have is real if Danny was just
into it because he was attracted to the
character of rock zet he would never
have done those things Danny and Karl
fight it out which is pretty much two
dudes releasing months of sexual
frustration they have in essence become
striking vipers only this time they're
not fighting in a game world Danny is
picked up by Theo at the police station
in question in the car about what
exactly is going on between him and Karl
before it cuts to black and we fast
forward to Danny's 40th birthday
remember at the beginning we were
celebrating Danny's 38 so some time has
passed now we never really know what
Danny told Theo but the next few scenes
suggests that he told her the truth and
have since come to an agreement for his
birthday Danny can fulfill his online
fun with Karl without any of the secrets
and hurt while Pheo can hook up with
randoms at the bar
they both exchange symbols of this new
trust Theo gives Danny his VR set and
Danny gives her her wedding box so that
she'll have somewhere to put a ring when
she goes out to the bar they both tell
each other that they have to give it
back in the morning
now it's uncertain whether this is just
for Danny's birthday or if this is a
monthly thing but it's definitely a step
in the right direction although this
episode deals a lot with sexuality it's
really about honesty and communication
and how other relationships are hurt by
not being open about how we truly feel
it's only when Danny is fully honest
with Theo that their relationship can
heal and they can once again be
passionate with each other and now on to
the fun part where we pick apart some of
the black mirror Easter eggs found in
this episode striking Vipers is directed
by Owen Harris who previously directed
black mirror episodes be right back and
San Junipero and there are quite a few
nods to sand Junipero in this episode
for example the company that makes the
VR set is TCK are the same company
responsible for uploading people's
consciousness to the cloud in San
Junipero the VR set also looks similar
to those used in that episode as well
TCK are although not confirmed is likely
an offshoot of Bandersnatch 'as Tucker
saw founded by Mohan Tucker Tucker is
also seen as trending in the next
episode smithereens along with Saito
gamoo which is the company that makes
striking Vipers speaking of striking
Vipers we have two versions of the game
the original which Carl and Danny play
at the beginning and striking Vipers X
or the Roman numeral 410 which takes
place eleven years later so it's safe to
assume there have been at least 10
different versions of this game one for
each year that has passed since the boys
first started playing in the game we get
a reference to tundra a white bear just
like the episode titled white bear and a
level called Saito helipad which Carl
and Danny appear on in the last shot of
the episode you'll also notice as the
camera zooms out the image of striking
Vipers on the side of the building Danny
also gets a gift of lacy chocolate lacy
the main character from nosedive and is
it just me or does this character here
look a bit like the Bandersnatch monster
all right guys not a lot of whole Easter
eggs in this episode but I hope you
enjoyed the video be sure to LIKE and
subscribe and you can
to me on Twitter at think story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much